[Music]
I know you're scared
I know he's sitting here wondering how
you gonna pay for this breakfast level
on your car payment or your rent how
much you two bills passed you by the way
huh how much credit card debt you got
right now how many times the last sweep
did your credit card decline
so you can cut this tough-guy attitude
with me believe me I'm not impressed
see there's two things you got to keep
in mind one things can change - you
gotta change
I've said exactly what you're sitting
here right now I said long be broke in
the tray the tray by my boss that
couldn't care less about my future
betray by the girls I couldn't care less
about my future but trib are my friends
who couldn't kill us about my dreams
challenge with you is beating the world
is against you
the world's not against you it's jus
against you the way you're going right
now this is the perfect hat for
self-destruction
your boss betrays you so what go get
into sales and learn how to make your
own money all these girls are trying to
impress with the money you don't have
whole wallet and your friends why you
trying to show off tonight the right
ones will accept indifference with your
long time
we got to figure out it with a big
yourself out not by going to Vegas and
trying to win on the blackjack day but
we're trying to get lucky I'm talking a
long term thinking I know you've gone
through a lot of tough times I know you
have a lot of experience trusts I
understand that things can change
you got a chance
but I can sense to you
[Music]
hey hun anything else you need I got a
family right
[Music]
it's gonna be interesting who shows up
good paddle baptized
what do you think he's a good kid we'll
be fine
[Music]
you